c'est dans la véranda de cette maison à
l'extérieur de châtillon en bazois que
les deux corps ont été retrouvés hier
après midi un couple âgé de 64 et 60 ans
lui pompiers retraités l éducatrice au
centre social du village robert et
martin des voisins sans problème on les
connaît c'est bien il était était là
depuis un certain nombre d'années déjà
et on n'y avait pas de problèmes on ne
les fréquente est pas personnellement
mais les rapports étaient dont il disait
toujours bonjour toujours un signe de la
main en passant
aucun problème particulier on m'a même
dit pour m'en aller
oumhani n'hésitez pas occitan que ça
soit 2 jours vous donnez vous m'appelez
les deux corps présentait des blessures
à la tête et un pistolet a été retrouvé
dans la véranda
à ce stade toutes les pistes restent
ouvertes mais le sexagénaire posséder
une licence de tir sportif et les
premiers éléments pourraient laisser
penser à un drame conjugal
lorsque les enquêteurs interviennent
très rapidement effectivement il n'y a
pas de trace d'effraction quelconque
endroit de leur de leur domicile ce qui
laisse à penser qu'effectivement le coup
de feu les coups de feu auraient été
tirés par l'un des deux est l'hypothèse
des hypothèses qui se pose pour le pour
le moment serait celle effectivement
d'un coup de feu tiré par l'un des deux
qui ensuite aurait retourné l'armé
contre contre lui-même
une enquête a été ouverte par le parquet
de nevers pour recherche des causes de
la mort une autopsie devrait apporter
des éléments de réponse
elle aura lieu dans les prochains jours
à l'institut médico-légal de
clermont-ferrand